hello everyone i'm samitra ganesh from
jpmorgan ai research
and today i will be presenting our work
on agent-based modeling
using multi-agent reinforcement learning
so in this work we are primarily
interested in modeling complex economic
systems
and these systems can be quite naturally
modeled as multiple agents interacting
with each other
there are three key characteristics of
these systems that are important from a
modeling standpoint
firstly we assume that every agent is
rational
and tries to maximize its utility or
reward
given the information and actions
available to it
secondly agents are constrained in their
observations and actions
for instance they only have partial
observations of the system
the third key aspect sorry
the third key aspect is that agents are
heterogeneous
and can have different reward functions
and constraints
a simple example of this is a market
like you see here
where on one hand you have merchants who
sell widgets at some price that they set
and they have to manage the inventory of
these widgets and on the other hand you
have customers
who generate demand compare prices from
different merchants
and decide who to buy from now all
merchants are rational
they want to maximize their revenue
while minimizing risk
but they are not identical firstly they
might have different levels of risk
aversion
that is they might make different
trade-offs between revenue versus risk
in their reward function
secondly they might have different
constraints some merchants might be more
connected to customers than
others capturing this heterogeneity
is very important in building a
realistic model of this market
now agent-based models can be powerful
engines for counter factual analysis
you can pose what-if scenarios like what
if there is a global pandemic and a
severe supply-side shock
to this market what would happen if you
have an agent-based model of this little
market
you could use it to analyze possible
outcomes and this is why we are
so invested in this problem because we
believe agent-based models can be a very
useful tool
for counter-factual analysis scenario
planning and risk management in finance
but in practice there are two hard
questions you have to solve to be able
to do this
firstly how do you learn rational
behaviors across
heterogeneous agents in a scalable
manner
and secondly how do you set the agent
composition the reward functions and
constraints of the agents
based on some real data and these are
the two questions that we tackle in our
recent europe's paper
we show that we can learn realistic or
rational behaviors
for different agents for a given agent
composition
by using a shared policy that's
conditioned on the agent parameters
in the paper we also analyze the game
theoretic implications of this approach
we also propose a new algorithm for
calibrating the agent-based model
where we estimate the agent composition
to match certain specified calibration
targets
while simultaneously learning the agent
behaviors
so i will touch briefly on the key ideas
in both of these contributions
but first let's formalize the
setup the agent-based model can be
formally described as a general sum
partially observable markov game where
each agent
observes its own state actions and
rewards
the combined state of the system evolves
as a function of the current state of
all agents
and their actions what is really key
is how we characterize the agent
heterogeneity and the space of agent
compositions
so this is how we do it each agent is
associated with a type
which is a vector of real numbers that
parameterizes its reward function and
constraints
so in the market example for instance
the merchant agent parameters would be
risk aversion and connectivity
we also have a small number of what we
call super types
each super type is a distribution over
the typespace
and each agent is assigned a supertype
and its type vector is then sampled from
this distribution
in each episode or simulation
so the set of supertypes essentially
specifies the agent composition for the
model
okay so now let's assume we have a fixed
set of super types or agent composition
how do we learn rational behaviors for
the different agents
our approach is to use a shared policy
condition on the agent type so each
agent
can plug in its state and type vector
lambda
and into this policy pi and sample in
action
the policy is then trained using the
individual experiences
of all the agents now this kind of
parameter sharing or centralized
training approach is pretty common
in recent multi-agent oral literature
particularly in fully cooperative games
the main difference here is that we do
not allow full observability during
training
and we treat the experiences as separate
now from an agent-based model
perspective
this means that no agent possesses some
kind of secret source
so if you take two agents and you swap
their parameters lambda you would also
swap their behaviors
in the paper we also analyze what it
means
uh to do this from a game theoretic
perspective what does it mean to have
different agents use this kind of shared
policy approach
it turns out that you can construct a
two-player game based on the payoffs in
the agent-based model as follows
the first player in this abstract
two-player game
gets the expected reward of one agent
playing pi one
while all the other agents play pie true
and vice versa
so the gradient update for the shared
policy can then be seen as self-play
related to this two-player game where
you roughly improve
the uh the policy for one player while
holding all the others fixed
so now we have a scalable way to learn
rational behaviors for
heterogeneous agents how do we actually
set the agent composition
let's say we are given some calibration
targets f star based on real data
and a loss function and we would like to
find the agent composition
or the set of super types such that this
calibration loss is minimized
so we are essentially going to tweak
these super type distributions
to minimize the calibration loss but
this can still be quite expensive
because this is a bi-level optimization
problem where for every choice
of super types we need to in principle
train the agent's shared policy until
equilibrium is reached
and then record the calibration loss
what we propose in our paper is a new
algorithm
where you have an oral based calibrator
agent which picks the increment in super
type space as its action
and it gets a reward that's the inverse
of the calibration laws
the calibrator policy and the shared
policy are both updated
but the calibrator policy is updated
less frequently than the shared policy
what this means is that we are able to
carry forward the shared policy from
previous iterations
and adapt it to the new super type
profile set by the calibrator agent
now in our experiments we compared this
to a bayesian optimization baseline
and we found that our algorithm which is
calculated in blue here
versus bayesian optimization in orange
is able to vary the super type profile
smoothly and this in turn results in
stable shared policy learning
because the shared call because thank
you because the shared policy is
sufficiently
uh able to adapt and keep up with the
super types being chosen
by the calibrator agent and so in these
plots you can see the calibrator agent
reward on the top row and the uh
shared policy reward on the bottom row
and these are two different experiments
and especially in the second experiment
you can see that the bayesian
optimization takes a large step in super
type space
and that completely throws off the
shared policy learning
so with these contributions we have
taken a step towards making the building
of realistic agent-based models
more efficient and scalable for
practical use
uh there is a lot a lot more to do
but this is uh only one of
i don't know 80 ongoing projects at
jpmorgan ai research
i want to introduce our team a little
bit because you know i often get
questions like oh jpmorgan has an ai
research team
uh our projects are actually quite
diverse and they're inspired by seven
goals that we have identified for our
team
so it ranges from eradicating financial
crime to empowering our employees
these are bold ambitious goals and they
encapsulate
the impact that we aspire to make
we are also a very diverse broad tent ai
team
we have researchers working on
everything from knowledge representation
and ai planning
to fairness and privacy issues in ai
we are hiring uh and we also have a
faculty
research award program i notice there
are a lot of
new faculty uh members here uh so yeah
if you're interested
please check us out at jpmorgan.com
ai thank you